it's one thing to get what you want but
it's another thing to want what's worth
getting that's from Shane Parish the
danger of not spending time working out
what you want to want can cause you to
move in the wrong direction Kyle Ean rer
explains it so well blindly following
your desires makes you a slave to your
impulses the advertisements you're
exposed to and the confused chemical
signals of your body if we don't pause
and ask ourselves what we want to want
we will spend our lives focused on
unhealthy aims defined for us by others
the worst parts of ourselves if we don't
cut to the core and program our wants
then our best case scenario is to be a
rich famous or successful slave in short
your default factory settings are
don't follow them the people who do this
are never going to fully actualize their
potential either for happiness or for
Success what you want is to be able to
arrive at a place where the things that
you want are the things that you want to
want and that's why desires are
important so yes your life should be
lived by Design not default